it started as a plume of smoke in the
southwest valley before long that smoke
had spread across the sky as the sandy
valley fire spread
now no structures are at risk however a
boy scout troop
had to be evacuated from the area not
too far from mount podesy
orkomana is on the scene tonight and
joins us with more orca
brian according to the national
interagency fire center
the sandy valley fire has burned around
15 hundred acres the fire here started
at around 1 30 this afternoon and you
can see the flames are still visible at
this hour
we're told the fire is still zero
percent contained right now
as crews tried to put it out
the sandy valley fire covering this
mountain area just
outside las vegas the flames spreading
thursday
covering hundreds of acres emergency
crews doing their best to tackle the
fire
and any hot spots that emerge the smoke
billowing into the sky could be seen for
miles across the
valley saw the plume and wanted to run
out to potassium
this man tells me he's part of a local
astronomy society and wanted to make
sure the astronomy site up here was ok
i just can't really draw judgment i mean
there's fires that go all over the place
and some don't do any damage and some do
so
just a matter of guesswork the bureau of
land management
u.s forest service and local fire
departments are all hard at work
campers in a boy scout troop evacuating
the area earlier as a precaution
but no injuries or structural damage
have been reported
officials say the fire was human caused
but they're still determining what
exactly happened
meanwhile people in the area are still
stunned by the situation
you could see the flames and the sun
looked red
earlier so when we were coming out oh we
can see
whatever that is so we thought oh stop
by and look at it
again the good news right now is that
there have been no reports of any
injuries or any damaged structures
fire crews are still working on
containment which again at last check
is at zero percent as they continue to
investigate
what exactly caused it stay with us for
updates reporting live tonight orco mana
8 news now